okay here's something very cool that is
going on we did a big giveaway a while
back of a 32-gigabyte david pakman show
USB flash drives the company that made
these drives really wants us to do
another giveaway so they said hey David
we're going to send you ate more of
those 32 gigabyte USB flash drives for
free now this is very very nice of them
to do but I don't need any of these 8 32
gigabyte david pakman show flash drives
we have plenty of flash drives here for
the work that we do so I'm going to give
them away to you okay and here's how
it's going to work this is super super
simple if you want a free 32 gigabyte
david pakman show USB flash drive the
first eight people to sign up for a
yearly membership with a particular
coupon code will get not only the USB
flash drive for free but also a
20-percent discount off of your
membership shipping is included if you
live in the united states if you live
outside the US uh shipping but we have
to pay for that shipping additionally so
that is going to be extra the coupon
code is and I would encourage you to
write this down flash drive 32 no spaces
all one word flash drive 32 because we
have eight flash drives the code will
work eight times and it will only work
for yearly memberships so the process is
you go to david pakman.com slash
membership you pick any price yearly
membership you want doesn't matter any
yearly membership qualifies you click
sign up and on the next page that comes
up you will see a coupon code field you
enter flash drive 32 it'll subtract
twenty percent from your membership
price and it will allow us to send you a
flash drive for free will reach out to
you after you sign up to get your
mailing address don't worry about that
let's do this thing I don't anticipate
that these are going to last uh to too
long gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4
ps3 wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low use price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at gamefly
offer.com / TDPS the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the david
pakman show audience and support our
show by going to gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s